Paul eunuch still can't believe it as he
walks through the ruins of the houses he
lived in the Dominican City Santiago
together with several other Haitians and
Dominicans with Haitian roots until the
immigration police came he says and
smashed everything to pieces maybe it's
important I tell you this but if the
Dominican police found out he says my
life would be in danger I have a wife
and children in haiti I don't want to be
killed here those kinds of patrols are
no rare occurrence the policy for
undocumented immigrants is to deport
them but even those with papers face
discrimination says killeen Vincent of
all the people I know she says the
Dominicans are the biggest racists of
them all we all have the same blood but
they live in two worlds
early in the morning we drive to the
dahab on river on the border between
haiti and the dominican republic two
countries on the single island of
Hispaniola tens of thousands of Haitians
stand at the border bridge and wait for
the guards to open the gates most want
to go to the Dominican market to shop or
to sell their own goods but many says
father Regina Martinez want to stay here
and there are thorn in the side of his
countrymen the relations between
Haitians and Dominicans he says are
marked by prejudice aunty Haitian ISM
racism and xenophobia we think of
ourselves as Spanish and European while
they're Africans slaves but the
Dominican Republic benefits greatly from
the cheap labor as much in the interior
as here at the market the Dominican
Republic is far from wealthy but when
the Haitian migrants compare it to their
home country it looks like the promised
land we're earning good money is easy
for decades the Dominican government
invited Haitians into the country to do
the construction and agricultural labor
that no Dominicans wanted to do more
than eighty percent of the workers at
banana plantations come from Haiti guest
workers have been in the Dominican
Republic for 100 years but there's
always been conflict between the two
nationalities reneik Liz Nell has been
in the Dominican Republic for six years
with his wife two children and his
sister he's worked in construction and
the sugarcane fields his meager income
pays the rent on his wooden shack and
for food Renee never leaves the farm
except to go shopping it's too dangerous
he says they've all been robbed harassed
or beaten
and he can't go to the police well Aviva
living here illegally we could try to
register but my employer won't confirm
that I work here that's why they
wouldn't give me any papers we could be
found out at any point we're constantly
living in fear Levon / fussing far from
the banana fields in a capital Santo
Domingo politicians are delighted at the
arrival of some foreigners more than 4
million come every year as tourists and
the money they spend is vital to the
economy but politicians don't feel the
same way about Haitian immigrants they
even changed the constitution in 2010 to
deny citizenship to the children of
undocumented immigrants what I want you
to understand is that a situation has
been building up for year says
government spokesman Roberto Rodriguez
and we the Dominicans have decided to
create order that's it we're in a
situation of perfect coexistence they
can be busier but fake that that order
approved catastrophic for yuliana deck
is pure she's the daughter of a guest
worker she was illiterate and is now
learning how to read so she can become a
teacher yuliana was born here in the
Dominican Republic and that made her a
citizen just like her daughter Nairobi
but when she went to renew her passport
the authorities confiscated all her
papers I have to stay much longer she
says so I can study and do everything to
become a teacher
now at 24 years old Giuliana is
stateless without papers she can neither
work nor travel she can't even prove
she's near op's mother Juliana takes us
to her beatty that's the word for the
settlements outside the cities where
many Haitian immigrants and their
descendants live that much she can stand
but now yuliana says they're robbing her
of her identity her mother lived her
entire life here without papers but
Giuliana's children born on Dominican
soil got birth certificates and
citizenship lisa kimmell so long they
say i'm not dominican because my parents
are foreigners who came here illegally
but I don't know anything else I say
even if our parents are foreigners I
don't feel like one all I have is my
birth certificate from here in the
Dominican Republic it says I was born
here if I was born here I'm Dominican
see ya no misaki moulana es dominicana
porque Yamasaki government spokesman
Roberto Rodriguez says every country
decides for itself who's allowed in its
borders he says the Dominican government
is being accommodating and the Haitian
government has a very positive attitude
he says there's been a lot of support
from the international community
including the EU and the UN to help
provide Haitians with national IDs the
Dominican government even offered to
create centers here on Dominican soil
where the Haitian government could give
national IDs to its citizens in 3 garlic
chiropody identidad azusa daughter
Juliana was just one of many who lost
Dominican citizenship after a court
ruling last year that was based on the
new constitution she since become the
subject of a lawsuit against the
government saying the ruling breaks
international law Juliana is that limbo
Juliana is a legal limbo she's truly
stateless because she's not receiving
the protection of the country in which
he was born nor protection from any
other country the authorities are
assuming she's Haitian
that's all do um pray thought you Jana
has never been to Haiti she hasn't even
been to the border she doesn't know
anyone in Haiti she has no ties to
Haitian society been cool guanghua una
sociedad ap Anna authorities have
counted about 230,000 people who are
affected by the revised constitution
many are organizing themselves taking
care not to show anyone their papers out
of fear that they could be deported I
problema amore there are really serious
problems there are young people who
can't go to university there are young
people who can't get an ID so they can
get a loan from a bank they can't get
social insurance they can't get a
passport the old Constitution didn't
require me to be legalized because I was
already Dominican now I can't be
legalized boring but I was born illegal
dominican lassie legal eres el this
group calls itself reconocido or
recognized all are Dominicans whose
parents or grandparents were immigrants
many have already had their papers taken
away Felipe 14 airs still has his ID
card he's a lawyer and his walls are
covered with a number of certificates
and degrees he's afraid to leave the
country if he loses his passport at the
border he also loses his right to work
he has three children to feed now he's
trying to prepare for the worst mrs.
compilers these kinds of campaigns never
aired well yay because when you teach
people to hate when you teach to deny
people's humanity there comes a point
when feelings turn into actions that's
very dangerous yes these people are
running a systematic campaign of hate
every day sometimes you don't know how
far it will be a signal Sally
I fell on the Buddha hastily guard the
hate has taken root among many
dominicans this nationalist group films
us out of mistrust but they make no
effort to hide their views if when my
sucker they've massacred our people
they're beating us up walk walk walk
walk bit by bit says this man they're
pushing us out of our own country but
we're going to fight back we can live in
peace says this woman with them over
there and us here their slogan is co
dead limpiar or a cleaned-up city these
kinds of xenophobic groups are cropping
up across the country they want to bring
their government's policy to every last
village the group's president wags his
finger saying too many haitians here boy
double dollars please give them access
to all our services he says hospitals
and schools everywhere i'm showing you
so you can see where they live how they
live what this situation is like and the
conflict between the Haitians and the
Dominicans auntie haitian groups like
this one ignore the fact that many here
have Dominican birth certificates and
our only living like this because
they're haitian origin prevents them
from finding housing anywhere else the
self-proclaimed City cleansers are also
not bothered by the squalid conditions
of the slums only that they are close to
their own homes
this woman laws Brito takes us to the
market to show how important their work
is look around she says they're all
Haitians here but people she so
aggressively point2 can do little but
look on in disbelief at her brashness
her rhetoric seems designed to pin the
blame on the victims of the racism by
accusing them of a similar slander in
their own minds they think the entire
island is Haiti so they call us the
intruders that we're not even from here
yuliana finds it terrible to live in a
country that doesn't want her she
doesn't know what will happen to her or
her children but if the authorities try
to deport her she plans to fight your
legacy I know our parents were
foreigners but we don't feel like
foreigners we all feel Dominican like
all other Dominicans and we're fighting
for our rights pocono cyclist on route
on bombers truly Rachel
you